hello and welcome to it's 9 50 in the
morning and we're making corn chowder
because as adults you could do whatever
you want it might not be rational
reasonable but it's really fun
[Music]
oh no hi my name is grace help me if you
don't know now you know your life is
different now we're in the kitchen we're
cooking it's 20 22. we're all hopped up
on our resolutions and or we're starting
a slow decline into the depression that
comes with not following these
resolutions that we've set for ourselves
we are our greatest cheerleaders and our
own worst enemies
let's make something to eat that's right
today i have decided to make sweet corn
and poblano chowder because it's a gray
day here in los angeles it's winter this
seems cozy and also when i order from
hellofresh i usually go for like full
meals and i saw this chowder on there
it's something i wouldn't normally
choose and i thought new year i'm making
choices so that's what we're doing today
but before we get into cooking obviously
we have to talk about some crucial
points some might call these talking
points i call them specific items that i
want to communicate to you verbally if
you're tired of setting unrealistic new
year's resolutions guess what this year
you can do things differently you can
regain control of your food choices with
hellofresh they have so many different
recipes to choose from so you can really
break out of your recipe rut which is
what i'm doing today 2021 right 2022
row no rut if you're strapped for time
don't worry they make quick and easy
recipes that can get done in under 20
minutes they have easy clean up and low
prep options because all the ingredients
are pre-portioned for you with
hellofresh you have less food waste and
less time wasted waste all that time
just beating yourself up over those
resolutions you're not getting done
that's healthy all right i have a very
busy day today so let's just get into
this right now everything you need to
make a hello fresh meal comes in this
handy dandy brown paper bag that
has no eggs in it most of the time and i
assume that this is one of them and it
is yes we're always right we're never
wrong i was going to pressure my ego i'm
doing a lot of schoolwork lately guys
wow wow i'm very into how all of this
looks right now aesthetically
chaotic good and don't forget you can
use this brown paper bag as a little
garbage bag for all your ingredients
while you cook i've never made chowder i
don't think i have probably accidentally
made thick soup or runny mashed potatoes
both of which could probably be
assumed to be chowder but you know not i
haven't set out with the intention of
making chowder and done it so that's
what we're gonna do today step number
one we are going to preheat our oven to
425 degrees
okay then we're gonna wash and dry all
of our produce look i took a shower it's
only right that you guys take a shower
hey baby gorgeous oh and i'm drinking
coffee because everyone knows coffee and
chowder what am i from boston
some people in boston do core deseed and
dice this poblano pepper and then we're
gonna chop up these potatoes into
half-inch pieces so we're going to
de-seed sorry and just like that you are
not able to have children anymore cute
look at this perfect oh god they're
everywhere this says this recipe takes a
total of 40 minutes that's about the
amount of time that i have before i have
to go to a meeting pardon me if we don't
have as much time to chit chat about the
important happenings in both of our
lives how can i update you on what's
going on with me
um how about this just mind your
business peppers are chopped
and i don't know much about chowder so
it's perfect
you know it's okay
you want it to be an art student i know
nothing about chowder so it's perfect
for me to assume that this is a
vegetarian
meal but perhaps you could add
meat to it what i would say for you to
do if you're interested in that is to
google it and find out from someone else
that knows what they're talking about we
need to finely dice half of the shallot
bam drain and rinse our corn which comes
in this box
like all delicious corn does you can
either drain your corn in a colander or
you could let it like
look at twitter for a second
step two
we're gonna melt two tablespoons of
butter in a medium pot we're gonna add
the poblano the diced shallot and season
with salt and pepper and cook for two to
three minutes i got
a tub of butter here we go whoa and then
we're gonna add the poblano
and the shallot
right the whole shallot
nothing but the shallot
and the shallot oil shallow in and now
salt pepper
i'm doing chef and cooking and this is
where we read the directions again
because we don't trust that we
actually committed them to memory or
read them correctly
that goes two to three minutes then we
add the flour stirring until lightly
browned for one minute and then we
slowly add our milk and then we add one
and a half cups of water again i just
said all of it and i didn't really
retain any of it this this water yeah
okay
oh that smells good it smells like food
as about ish so now we put our flour in
and cook for a minute until it's
brownish and i have no sense of what a
minute is because i'm impatient so now
i'm just gonna slowly put in the milk
and incorporate that right now we
stirring one and a half cups of water
okay now we're gonna add the potatoes
the stock concentrate which is these
guys you guys look very focused these
are the guys that you want to go to for
adderall that's a focus joke very milky
very interesting color it smells
good smells like milk and potatoes oh
half a little bit forgot half the old
bed wow that made the color
different again gorgeous oh it is hatsey
taxi in here i'm dressed like i look
like i'm going to a ski lodge oh what
are we doing now we bring to a boil and
cook stirring occasionally until the
potatoes are very tender 15 to 20
minutes all right i'm gonna put a lid on
this so it cooks faster because
i
have no ability to remember anything and
no patience how about that ah there is a
little note that says you can add shrimp
to this see
i was right i hate to admit it but i'm
right all the time i keep telling my
therapist that she doesn't really say
anything which makes me assume that she
agrees where was i ah this is going to
cook for 15 to 20 minutes so the
potatoes can get tender and delicious
and then we're just gonna you'll see the
next step when the next step happens
we're still waiting
sharp things randomly everywhere we're
still waiting for the chowder to cook
with the potatoes but in the meantime
we're gonna work on our old bay seasoned
bread so we need softened butter or i'm
just gonna melt butter because i only
have
butter in a tub which is a true luxury
look at it go my gosh cook those
potatoes butter has been melted put a
quarter teaspoon of old bay seasoning
and a quarter teaspoon of sugar i don't
want to do that we'll just do whatever
we want to do here's our old bay a
quarter of a teaspoon i like old bay so
that might have been more mix it in with
our butter take our baguette we're going
to cut it in half did i cut that
correctly there are two pieces now i
don't they're supposed to go this way
who gives a sh now on a baking sheet we
put our bread get our little kitchen
paint brush we just uh
take our butter and paint the top of
this red with it this is also how i do
my makeup if you're wondering smash it
on there
who wore better picasso could never
he could well he actually could never
he's dead
sorry now we toast this in the oven for
three to five minutes we are burning
through this we'll be right back after
this commercial break to finish what we
started with this chowder i figured now
while the chowder is still chowdering
that i would tell you guys the
hellofresh offer if you are interested
in participating in this beautiful
cooking experience if you are you can go
to hellofresh.com you can use my code
hellbig16 for up to 16 free meals a butt
ton of meals and three surprise gifts i
know ominous intriguing curious
confusing again you can go to
hellofresh.com use my code helbig16 to
get up to 16 free meals and three
surprise gifts i hope it's a cheesecake
factory gift card that would be ironic
so our timer's almost gonna go off which
means that the potatoes have been
cooking for like 15 minutes and
basically you should cook them until
they're tender so they might need more
time to go but the bread should be done
soon so that's just where we're at i've
also realized that in the past couple
years i've gotten very obsessive with
making sure people know what's going on
probably a reaction to the insane lack
of certainty the world has held for all
of us the last couple years but who's to
say
my therapist that's who
oh this doesn't go off until i do it
okay i didn't need this pan this whole
time i just wanted you to see it isn't
it pretty i got a new
our place pan and i love it okay it's
still it could use a little bit more so
from reading the recipe who knew that
was a
major component in this whole experience
once the potatoes are tender we're going
to reduce the heat and mash them to a
desired consistency i don't have a
potato masher remind me to buy a potato
masher and a meat thermometer i need one
of those too remind me of that okay
we're going to reduce the heat to low
we're going to use a fork and struggle
to mash up some potatoes in this pot
until we get a desired consistency which
i'm pretty sure will happen very quickly
as i
don't like spending a long time on
things
[Music]
or bread let me check on the bread i
don't want to burn the bread that's a
desired consistency because i desire to
be done doing that we're going to stir
in our cream cheese our corn and our
monterey jack until it's fully
incorporated watch this cream cheese
always stunning always a stunning
element to add our corn it's just been
chilling hey corn and our monterey jack
oh it's going everywhere okay now we
stir all this in make sure that cream
cheese really melts in there that's
looking like chowder i think as i have
no
direct
personal references to compare it to
that's full-on freaking chowder i think
we're gonna add some salt and pepper
some full-on thick
soup this is like if soup
decided it was gonna do hot girl winter
and it got itself all thick that
honestly i think looks really great
let's set this meal up oh my gosh okay
this was all relatively easy i found a
ladle well elliot found a ladle the
other day i thought i didn't have one
if you wonder what i've been up to big
things now i'm supposed to garnish with
a dollop of sour cream
[Music]
this is how they look in their profile
picture and this is how they show up and
you're like damn thick and full of
corn there is a god doesn't make sense
but what does other than science science
deeply make sense okay sweet corn and
poblano chowder at 10 42 a.m
that all is great
whoa
wow that's very nice i'm not a chowder
person but today i am and that's
delicious it's a little sweet because
the corn and then the old bay is like
smoky and reminds me of bloody mary's in
maryland the poblano's a little bit
spicy and i don't really know how uh to
describe things correctly i'm just
talking out of my ass and this probably
will too in about half hour yeah i'm a
big fan of this oh my god i think this
is maybe a sign of adulthood and
maturing as an individual is that
you like soups more and you get it all
over yourself oh no well there you go
this was delicious i will be eating this
throughout the rest of the day i hope
you enjoyed this video if you did let me
know in some capacity and i hope you
enjoy your day
other than that
i don't know
chowder is where it's at
said no gen zir ever